Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
made a whirlwind visit to Washington
culminating in a speech at the National
Archives there is not a soul in Ukraine
that does not feel gratitude to you
America
the Ukrainian Leader's message to
officials in Washington particularly on
Capitol Hill
Ukraine's counter-offensive against
Russian forces is at a critical juncture
and now is not the time to curb support
since the start of Russia's Invasion the
United States has provided more than 135
billion in Aid to Ukraine now the White
House is asking Congress to approve 25
billion more
but that request is contentious
especially among conservatives I don't
support additional funding for Ukraine
my view is we need to number one take
care of our folks first still President
Joe Biden confirmed U.S Abrams Tanks
will be delivered to Ukraine by next
week a new Aid package consisting of
ammunition rocket launchers and
anti-armor systems totaling 325 million
was also announced on Thursday
but as zielinski sat down in the Oval
Office for his sixth face-to-face
meeting with Biden he urged the U.S
president to also provide longer-range
missile systems to help Ukraine win back
territory and it expanded bilat with
cabinet officials Biden assured
zielinski White House support is
unwavering we're committed to help
Ukraine build a force capable of
ensuring Ukraine's long-term security
capable of deterring future threats
against sovereignty territorial
integrity and freedom which are underway
now
because that's what this is all about
the future
the future of freedom but not all share
that sentiment most polls show waning
American voter support for Ukraine Aid
the Ukrainian Leader's requests may also
be overshadowed by a battle over
government spending in the U.S Congress
Democratic and Republican lawmakers face
an end of the month deadline to approve
domestic funding or face a potential
government shutdown
Kimberly halken Al Jazeera the White
House
the head of Sudan's ruling
council's morning
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera